[Musique]
comme chaque lundi vous nous donner les
derniers résultats sportifs du week end
commence par du handball direction le
championnat de pré régionale c'est ça on
joue et la 8e journée ce samedi 24
novembre et les bleu et blanc de trappes
sont imposés tout en maîtrise face au
mur au dernier du classement de cette
première régionale les trappistes
l'emportent 43 à 35 dans leur gymnase à
après un festival offensif on écoute les
réactions micro de notre journaliste
nicolas d'ambré je pense que les mérites
et on s'est tous donné à 200 %
on a su jouer même physiquement jusqu'au
bout malgré des trous défensif qui nous
ont fait mal
certaines périodes mais sinon dans
l'ensemble c'était de ces travaux
l'équipe en face était on va dire sur le
papier moins fort qui se sont renforcées
mais ça reste une équipe qui était
largement à notre portée normalement
mais une équipe que le leader a battu
que de six buts la semaine dernière donc
là on leur met sept buts
l'objectif est atteint résultat qui
pourrait être un tournant dans la saison
des trappistes cette deuxième victoire
consécutive permet aux joueurs de
frédéric bélanger de grimper à la 4e
place du championnat après huit matches
disputés la montée l'objectif du club
semble accessible le premier à deux
points devant donc une victoire étant à
trois points tout et tout est très serré
et vu qu'il ya 2 2 places pour monter en
région c'est encore tout à fait faisable
maintenant faudra faire mieux mais voilà
on est on est on est on est dans l'est
on est dans les places on est encore en
vie des trappes continuera de tentera de
continuer sa remontée à date je vais
réussir à le dire grégory dès le mois de
janvier prochain après la brève trêve
hivernale et rapide se déplaçant sur le
terrain à de belles vous aimez ça la
raie manta d'âge mental à wesley
matthews et mos si on continue toujours
du handball mais mais côté féminin cette
fois-ci voilà montigny-le-bretonneux a
lourdement chuté sur le terrain de rouen
lors de la 8e journée du championnat de
nationale 2 les îles montaigne se sont
inclinés à 29 à 20 à l'extérieur
au classement les yvelinoises reste à la
7e place avec un bilan négatif de 3
victoires pour déjà cinq défaites place
la trêve maintenant pour l'euro de
handball féminin le prochain match est
programmé le 12 janvier contre lisieux
on leur souhaite de se reposer pendant
les fêtes de noël et de ne pas abuser du
forum avec modération enfin duel du
basket pour finir 8e la 8e journée du
championnat de nationale 3 masculine
trappe se déplacer sur le terrain de
vineuil et les trappistes sont repartis
avec une victoire dans leur valise ils
se sont imposés sur le fil 72 à 67 dans
un match très serré au classement trappe
reprend la deuxième place à son
adversaire du jour et revient à un petit
point de la première place détenue par
poti merci votre émission le 7-8 sport
dans un instant de quoi parlera et vous
on recevra notamment un apnéiste xavier
delpy la plongée à plus de 100 mètres de
profondeur nous recevrons également
tristan au cou et dell qui participera
au rallye automobile africa eco race et
c'est à suivre
après ce journal mais